foreign
[Music]
faith and physics I'm your host Mary
Jane Rubinstein this evening's debate is
brought to you by The Institute for arts
and ideas in partnership with closer to
truth please find their interviews with
some of the most foremost thinkers of
our time at closer to truth.com
and now for some fantasy faith and
physics
we think that we pursue the Sciences
solely for knowledge and Truth but is
this a mistake untestable ideals like
Beauty have been baked into theories
throughout the history of science
Paul Dirac one of the greatest
scientists of the 20th century
proclaimed it is more important to have
Beauty in one's equations than to have
them fit experiment and recently Roger
Penrose described String Theory as a
fashion quantum physics as a faith and
Cosmic inflation as a fantasy arguing
that scientists suffer from the very
same prejudices that affect the rest of
us
do we pursue science out of a pure
desire for truth or should we accept
that some ex some assumptions especially
at the foundations of physics are akin
to religious beliefs dressed in
mathematical language
should we see science as simply another
theology or would that undermine the
field of physics and the progress it has
made over the past few centuries
we have I'm excited to tell you invited
four magnificent speakers to address
these questions today first Juan
malasena is world renowned for his
field-defining contributions to the
foundations of string theory and quantum
gravity he works at the institute for
advanced study in Princeton New Jersey
is a theoretical physicist who
specializes in quantum gravity she's the
author among other things of existential
physics a scientist's guide to Life's
biggest questions and then we have Max
tegmark who is a pioneering physicist
cosmologist and computer scientist based
at the Massachusetts Institute of
Technology he is the author of our
mathematical Universe which argues that
reality is fundamentally a mathematical
structure
and finally Michio Kaku is a famed
futurist and co-founder of string field
theory he has spent his career inspired
by the search for a Theory of Everything
his latest book is called Quantum
Supremacy how the quantum computer
Revolution will change everything okay a
quick word on format we will open the
conversation with two-minute responses
to an opening question and then we'll
move on to discuss three major themes
pertaining to this opening question all
right heading in here we go opening
question we are going to start with
Michio Kaku here we go two minutes on
the question Professor Kaku is
mathematical Beauty a guide to truth
please
well mathematical beauty is a guide to
truth but not the soul guy because
ultimately we have to rely on experiment
however when you look at the fundamental
theories without exception every single
fundamental theory has a description in
terms of beautiful gorgeous mathematics
so what do we mean by Beauty to a
physicist beauty is symmetry so when you
scramble objects you get the same thing
again after you do the manipulation and
so if you take a look at Einstein's
theory of gravity
reparametrizations in space-time
generates general relativity if you take
a look at the standard model uh s-u-n
special unitary groups and N Dimensions
is the Symmetry group of quarks for
example now hypothetically if you want
to win a Nobel Prize in physics or at
least be a contender your theory has to
at least explain three things things
first your theory would have to
incorporate Einstein's theory of gravity
which as I said before has a beautiful
Cemetery behind it second the standard
model your theory would have to explain
quarks and neutrinos and electrons and
all the zoo of subatomic particles that
we see in our atom Smashers that's the
second thing that your theory has to has
to explain third
anomalies and divergences if you simply
get a sheet of paper write Einstein's
theory try to quantize it what happens
it blows up in your face
because of the fact that there's
something missing a cancellation
mechanism to cancel the divergences now
so far the only Theory which can do all
three
is string theory now that doesn't mean
it's correct who knows maybe there's a
higher Theory someplace but the only
theory that can give a reasonable
explanation of all three characteristics
of a theory of everything is string
theory now of course there are competing
theories but they all fall down at some
point they have anomalies they diverge
they don't have electrons they don't
have matter as we know it there's always
something wrong with one of these
theories and so far the only Theory
which can pass these is string theory
now of course people of course can have
their own opinions about this thing some
people are critical but when I was a
child we used to play a game and the
game was put up or shut up that is if
you say something try to top it try to
say something even better or keep your
mouth shut so my attitude is very simple
you don't have to believe in a certain
Theory at all you can believe in another
theory but that other theory has to
satisfy these three criteria that I just
laid out that to me is the acid test of
whether you're embarking upon the true
road to understanding the universe if
you can't do it then well maybe you
should shut up
okay thank you so much Michelle Kaku has
thrown down
um let's move if we can to Sabina
hasenfelder can you answer the question
please address the question is
mathematical Beauty a guide to truth
I think I'm going to go with Definitely
Maybe So I think we develop our sense of
mathematical Beauty through experience
in physics we get this experience from
the theories that we work with and this
shapes our sense of beauty I think it's
often a sense that can't be formulated
in concrete mathematical requirement
requirements it's rather it's rather a
gut feeling a sense for what works and
what doesn't work and that's valuable
exactly because we can't strictly
formulate it and I also think this is
why some people are drawn to physics
instead of mathematics because you can
bring in this intuition this gut feeling
but this sense of beauty only helps us
as long as we stay in that corner of
mathematics which we have experience
with if we're looking for a completely
new theory that might use entirely
different mathematics it won't be of any
use we have to get there by other means
but once we get there we develop a
newfound sense of beauty and this has
happened several times in the history of
physics for example Kepler's elliptical
orbits were once thought of as ugly so
was the idea that the Universe expands
or quantum mechanics but we don't say
that today anymore we have developed a
new sense of beauty
so I think mathematical Beauty can be
helpful in cases when the new Theory
resembles the previous ones but if that
isn't the case it can stand in the way
string theory is a cautious example
businesses think it's beautiful because
it conforms to their sense of beauty
that they have developed from the
existing theories that doesn't mean it's
right though and then there are
alternatives like Loop quantum gravity
that many physicists think are ugly
because it uses very different
mathematics but that doesn't mean it's
wrong
fantastic thank you so much Max tegmark
is mathematical Beauty a guide to truth
I'm gonna go with yes and I want to take
a little historical perspective here of
course already in ancient times
thinkers like Plato and others
felt that there was something truly
beautiful about physics about nature
and even saw mathematics in music and in
the world around us since then I think
we've learned two main things one from
studying physics and one more recently
from studying artificial intelligence
from studying physics we've discovered
Evermore
beautiful patterns and not just
rotational symmetry translational
symmetry time translation Symmetry and
so on which were known for a very long
time but also new ones like what
michoaco referred to so-called gauge
symmetries that involve
properties of Elementary particles Etc
and eminenter showed us this beautiful
relationship between symmetries and
things that are more permanent in nature
stay conserved
so absolutely there there's something
there and we kept finding more but
artificial intelligence has very
recently also
shed light on what we even as until what
intelligent beings even
get drawn to it and and find interesting
in the world around them which says I
think very deeply related and AI if you
have some data set with a lot of numbers
and you can explain that data set with
much fewer numbers you're like ah this
is great
that is actually often used even as a
measure of intelligence how much you can
compress the data and that's only
possible if there are patterns in the
data that that you've uncovered
and uh I think to me something now feels
very beautiful even if it isn't in the
traditional sense of being symmetric but
if you just find patterns and structure
there for example there I once pulled
out a book in an old library Shelf with
about a hundred thousand numbers that
measured
the wavelength of spectral lines coming
out of atoms we can now compute all of
those hundred thousand numbers from
three numbers in the Schrodinger
equation
that's also Beauty in this AI sense
where you get way more out of the theory
that than you put into it
right thank you so much and finally Juan
malacena can you please let us know
whether in your world mathematical
beauty is a guide to truth
well I think beauty is a bit in the idol
either of the beholder so
I think that mathematical and physical
consistency is a guide to truth and by
by mathematical consistency I mean the
internal consistency of equations and by
physical consistency I mean that it
reduces to the known physics in the
appropriate regimes so here we are
talking about fundamental Theory So
Physical consistency includes reducing
to semi-classical general relativity and
also to the standard model of particle
physics I guess more generally we could
demand that it reduces to general
relativity plus some quantum theorem not
necessarily that of the standard model
now in the past it as as we discovered
deeper theories we found that they are
in some sense simpler
in the case of the standard model and
gravity they are also based on something
called the gauge principle which
involves a certain let's say so-called
symmetry it's not quite a symmetry in
the standard sense but
um to the extent that symmetry is
associated psychologically to Beauty
then you could call them beautiful and
for some reasons sometimes people say
theories which have a larger gauge group
are more beautiful but this is a bit
subjective we also have Concepts like
Simplicity as let's say in Occam's razor
so sometimes simpler theories are called
Beautiful
I mean I think the bottom line is that
the theory is beautiful when it works
and uh and by works I mean it's
mathematical and physically consistent
now of course whether theory is true or
not is decided on next by experiment so
if you agree but if if in order for a
theory to agree with experiment it
probably has to be as a necessary
condition physically or mathematically
consistent so I think those two
conditions are a guide um
and I will also end up here we're
talking about beauty of theories but I
would also say that sometimes
experiments are beautiful so they're
beautiful when they manage to do
something seemingly impossible for
example you could say that the Detectors
of gravity waves are beautiful in this
sense
thank you
this is amazing because you have
provided a brilliant transition into our
first theme question which kind of
intensifies the opening one
um Juan when you say a theory is
beautiful when it works which is to say
mathematically and physically what do we
do if these two are at odds with one
another
um our opening description cited Paul
Dirac is saying it is more important to
have Beauty in one's equations than to
have them fit experiment was he right
about that Max I'm going to send it over
to you first it's more important to have
Beauty in one's equations than to have
them fit experiment what do you think on
this
well it's sometimes better to be uh
wrong in an interesting way than right
in a boring way in in the sense that the
former can sometimes point the way
forward I think that's why he what Iraq
was getting at and I want to I want to
add what you Juan said there about
Occam's razor
because
I think when we say that a physics
theory needs to work right what we
really mean by that is not just that it
should be able to explain all the
measurements so far like all those
spectral lines in the book but that it
should also be able to predict new
things that we haven't seen yet and
that's where the beauty actually
of Simplicity really shines you know
this is well known in machine learning
that if you don't insist on having a
simple description you can find the
so-called overfitting description which
just memorizes all the data and it is
useless for predicting but the the more
beautiful your theory is in the sense of
being
being a minimalistic being short
having little information in it the more
it will generalize to the Future in a
sense there's this free lunch theorem as
well known in complexity theory that
says that if someone gives you just a
string of random numbers right there is
no algorithm there's no computer program
with fewer bits of information that can
just output that and so when we find uh
an a way a physics theory that can
describe a lot of data beautifully in
one sense in the sense in the Occam's
razor sense doing it with much less
information we know that this is just
not random data that we've actually
discovered some pattern and that's where
the power of generalization comes from
the power to make new predictions in
physics for things we haven't seen yet
and when you check you know wow the
prediction worked missio does that sound
right to you that you get us as simple
you get as simple as possible a theory
and you maximize the possibility that it
might fit in new experimental data
yes I think so and it goes back to when
I was in high school when I was in high
school I was struggling to learn the
Schrodinger wave equation which was
horrible it was ugly and I said to
myself how can God be so malicious to
create this short Angel wave equation
and then one day I picked up a book and
there was the Dirac equation
simple elegant gorgeous beautiful all
the the difficulties summarized into an
equation half an inch long the theory of
the electron and I began to cry
okay I've never done that before crying
over an equation and then I realized
there's something hidden there power
that beauty is not just for beauty's
sake it's power power to compute things
power to understand the universe and
then when I got into quantum gravity we
have to calculate the scattering of
gravitons and when you do that the loop
diagrams you get diverge they blow up in
your face and it seemed hopeless
absolutely hopeless to create a quantum
theory of gravity because every time you
calculate the finding diagrams they blow
up on your face and then one day one day
I read a paper where they showed that
there are actually two sets of finding
diagrams one set of family diagram has
let's say an electron going around and
the other one has a super electron going
around and they cancel exactly
this to me was a shock because it meant
that again
beauty is this not for beauty's sake
it's just not there to be admired and
people say oh wow that's pretty no it
has power power to eliminate the
divergences in fact to our knowledge the
only way known to eliminate the
divergences of quantum gravity is
through
supersymmetry so that super particles
cancel against each other such a simple
idea such a simple idea that has the
power to do something that the greatest
Minds could not do many people had given
up trying to quantize gravity because
every time you quantize gravity it blew
up in your face and there was a solution
symmetry super symmetry the symmetry of
particles canceling against their super
partners and of course we don't have any
experimental data concerning this yet
that's an embarrassment but in my heart
of hearts I think one day we'll find it
so theory is going to lead experiment
that nature is telling us something that
all the divergences of quantum gravity
are there for a reason pointing to the
direction of super symmetry which to our
knowledge is the only way to cancel the
horrible Infinities in quantum gravity
Sabrina hussenfelder how are we doing so
far you you and your opening statement
talked about the importance of
contextualizing our ideas of beauty that
different people find different
Generations particularly of people find
things beautiful at different times
um do Simplicity and symmetry are they
always beautiful are they beautiful from
a limited perspective are attachments to
Simplicity and symmetry perhaps leading
Us in the wrong way or do you think that
this is correct that if we stick with
the principles of Simplicity and
symmetry we will eventually find that
our Theory does in fact play out
experimentally
well it just didn't work with
supersymmetry right so I'm not sure
there's even that much of a question uh
like people have been looking for Grant
unified theories and supersymmetric
particles since the 1980s and they
haven't found them so clearly it doesn't
work but maybe let me uh let me come
back to the question you asked about
Dirac and his statement about beauty
because I think there are kind of he
became a victim of his own success so he
derived this beautiful equation
and he didn't really know why it worked
so he tried to come up with an
explanation and I think he stumbled on
this idea of beauty so he started
thinking that his sense of beauty was
what led to this success and he later
tried to use it again and it didn't work
for example with his
um what did he call it the large number
hypothesis
um so so it I found it interesting what
who owns said about consistencies or
inconsistencies because what Iraq was
actually doing with his equation was
that he was trying to remove an
inconsistency between special relativity
um and the then known version of the
Schrodinger equation so he he
misidentified the origin of his success
and to some extent was still suffering
from this today so string theory was
actually an approach to to try and
resolve an inconsistency as a machine
correctly said
um to my best knowledge it was never
actually proved that it did indeed
resolve the inconsistency
one do you want to come back here and
and weigh in
um
yeah well the regarding the question of
course if you take the question out of
context he's of course incorrect what
the ACT probably meant was that an
interest in mathematical structure might
lead to apparent contradiction with
experiment but usually there's a long
chain of reasoning in interpreting
experiments so he meant that perhaps
it's more likely that there is some
error in the chain of Reason in the
theory now
it's also true that their accent later
in his said this later in his life the
ark was trained as an engineer and for
him it was important that the questions
work in the sense that we mentioned
before
um and he was interested in symmetries
and general principles and of course he
had a tremendous success with the direct
equation and his prediction of the
positron he also suggested the existence
of monopods which have not yet been seen
but it's quite likely that they exist
um
and Sabina mentioned the fact that the
variation of the Newton constant with
them that's some the case where it
didn't work now an interesting example I
think for this is yam Mill's Theory so
when young and males propose the theory
it was supposed to apply for the
description of pions and and it did not
work
but later it was useful for the
development of the standard model so it
applied to the weak interactions and to
the strong interactions
another example is the following in 1939
in a thought Iraq said in a talk about
the power of mathematics and physics
that the group of analytic
Transformations on the plane on the
two-dimensional plane was an interesting
mathematical subject that might be
interesting for physics he didn't know
how
but actually in the 1980s this was
indeed brought to the study of phase
transitions in two Dimensions by 11
polarconological and we use it to
explain experiments and so on so that's
a case where you know some beautiful
mathematics then had some implications
for
um
let's find another example of a famous
mistake that turned out to be useful was
when Einstein felt
was mathematically elegant to include
the so-called cosmological constant in
his equations of gravity and then he
later called that his greatest blunder
and now of course in hindsight we know
he was right there is actually Dark
Energy in our universe and a lot more of
it than of the kind of atoms that make
up us
are there to move into the second theme
though
um May there be some assumptions that
can't be demonstrated experimentally or
that won't be demonstrated
experimentally should we accept the idea
that some of the assumptions of the
foundation of physics for example the
idea just that there is a grand unified
theory out there could be akin to
religious convictions are these sorts of
assumptions Faith dressed up as
mathematics um Sabina I will start with
you
well I guess it depends on what you mean
by accept so should we accept them as
established by evidence no of course not
because they aren't
sure we accept them as an inspiration
that physicists use to develop new
hypothesis uh it's fine with me because
I'm very pragmatic person you know for
what I'm concerned anything goes if
something comes out in the end but
there's there's a risk you know that
people run down uh dead ends and then
send in front of a wall and look at the
beautiful wall and we're not getting
anywhere so I think one has to be a
little bit mindful of
um you know what what is Faith and and
what is actually
um science
what about you Michio do you think that
these assumptions say that the notion
that there's a grand unified theory has
the structure of Faith or is it
different from faith
well personally I think that eventually
all things are testable it just means
that our instruments have to be souped
up to the point where they can reveal
the true nature of things for example
dark matter we don't know what dark
matter is it makes up most of the matter
of the universe some people think it is
a presence of supersymmetry which is of
course a symmetry of the string in
particular the fotino when you look at
the fortino you find that its properties
are what you want that it is massive it
has it's not massless and it is
invisible and that's exactly what dark
matter is if I held dark matter in my
hand it would be invisible and yet it
would sift right through my fingers we'd
never seen anything like that before on
a stable on a stable canvas of physics
but there it is in outer space now that
won't clinch String Theory but I think
it would go a long ways towards showing
the super symmetry is a legitimate
physical symmetry of the universe also
there are other ways of testing these
theories when we look at the fact that
string theory exists in other dimensions
some people laugh and say this is
science fiction but already scientists
are trying to look at deviations of the
inverse Square law this goes back to
Isaac Newton Newton would say that in
your living room gravity diminishes as
the universe Square across your living
room that has never been duplicated
experimentally but on now our
instruments are at the point where they
can and so we can look with deviations
of the inverse Square law which would
indicate the presence of higher
Dimensions also satellites in outer
space we're talking about Lisa laser
interferometry space antenna which will
give us the best look at creation itself
now of course it's very difficult to
look at the incident of creation so much
radiation existed back then but we hope
to get a snapshot of the instant of
creation and String Theory actually
takes you before the Big Bang String
Theory does not stop at the big bang it
gets even before the Big Bang and
therefore this gives you a testable
parameter by which you can rule out
certain string theories if they don't
fit the characteristics of the universe
as it was being created now of course we
cannot measure the universe before
creation but the universe at the instant
of creation itself I think will
eventually be measured by satellites and
that will give us a third way to test
these theories so in summary I think
that yes all gray theories can be tested
does anybody want to hop in here there
are two things that I'm hearing from
Michio that I think are you go go for it
Max yeah
first I I like to say that um to me the
def
the core principle of science is what is
humility
in in the sense that I would rather
have
questions I can't answer that answers I
can't question that's what I mean when I
say I'm I'm a scientist and that
humility includes always being open to
the idea that my pet theories are all
wrong but as Mitchell said always
testing them testing them testing them
I wanted to comment also on on what
Michio said about how more and more
things become testable
and make clear that
even if there are some things you cannot
test at all that doesn't mean that the
the theory that that came from itself
isn't scientific because when we test in
science
are theories
not things so for example Einstein's
theory of gravity is absolutely
scientific because it makes a lot of
predictions we can test and have tested
like Mitch you mentioned but it also
predicts what happens inside of black
holes which we cannot test and then come
back and publish it in the physics
journal
does that mean
relativity is unscientific of course not
it doesn't mean we shouldn't trust what
generativity predicts what happens
inside the black holes well as meet you
said if you want to replace if you don't
like what happens inside black holes you
got to come up with a new Theory
that that says something different about
what happens for the untestable but that
still Express explains everything else
that we can test and that's proven to be
super hard so many of today's biggest
controversies in physics
where some people are quick to dismiss
them as science fiction are exactly in
this category for example
inflation are the most popular theory
for what put the bang into our big bang
we don't currently have the technology
to go directly
measure some certain aspects of this but
this theory has already made a lot of
other predictions that have been very
successful and that's why we take it
seriously but with the humble
understanding that it might still be
wrong same thing there's been a lot of
talk about parallel universes there's a
number of you here have worked on that
are predicted by inflation some variants
there over or predicted of some variants
of quantum mechanics again you can't
necessarily go observe that directly but
if you can predict a lot of other things
if you can if you can test a lot of
other things predicted by
unitary quantum mechanics with no wave
function collapse right then you're
logically forced to take those things
seriously too so to summarize I don't
think the fact that some predictions of
a theory can't be tested at the moment
or ever in any way make the theory
itself non-scientific as long as it
predicts other things that we can test
because that means the theory is still
falsifiable
um we then have to have the humble
stands that it might be wrong
and just keep testing it
well and I hear you're making a
distinction perhaps between
unadulterated faith and uh something
like a scientific humility here um as an
answer to this question
um
the litmus test is unadulterated faith
is if someone says that I believe
proposition X to be true and there's no
data you could possibly give me that's
going to change my mind right whereas
the humility that defines science is if
you have a if you have something that
can be tested you should be able to
explain to people
with which test and which data you know
will will change your mind and always be
open to the idea that that you might be
wrong it's important to not get too
emotionally attached to our theories
Juan how are you doing in here
yeah so I think in order to propose a
theory we need to make some suppositions
so as a theorist you don't have to
believe them you just need to assume
them until you figure out the
consequences so you'll never invent a
new theory if you don't start with some
assumptions so for example you can
assume the universal Newtonian law
gravitation and then you can calculate
how planets will move
now you could assume a different theory
of gravity so for example you can assume
the north from theory of gravity or the
Einstein theory of gravity and then
figure out how planets move and then in
that way you can figure out which of
these theories is correct um You
probably never heard about the nostrum
theory because that's one that is
incorrect but it was suddenly one that
was proposed at the time
um
so
um now
you you only need to believe them while
you are doing the calculation or not
even believe them but you just need
logically deduce from some assumptions
now our current theories are
mathematically very complex and it is
very difficult to do calculations even
with the even with the Ethereal standard
model for example so this has led to the
kind of new breed of theorists uh I
think I'm among them uh who have
specialized in the structure of
fundamental theories and the um some
have been successfully tested like the
standard model and some have not so for
example strength there is one that has
not been tested against nature yet
um and we are happy to assume various
things at various points so we are happy
to assume granular Grand unification for
one Richard project and not to the next
in one paper we might assume string
theory in the net next we might
only assumes in my classical gravity or
only assume inflation and you know
inflation doesn't need String Theory so
you can only assume inflation nothing
else
um and in particular you don't need to
be consistent in your assumptions in the
sense that from one paper you assume one
thing and for the next paper you assume
another so it's not the type of
consistency that is required from a
politician or moral leader or whatever
so consistency is only required of
theories not theorists
[Laughter]
that's fascinating this sort of like
that sort of perspectival approach to it
that you work with in a particular
theory for a particular experimental
setup is this what you're saying
yes yes we're experimental set them and
you just to deduce the consequences of
those assumptions you might not uh know
exactly what they are because there is a
long chain of calculations and you need
to compare various theories and so on
um now we all have some beliefs like I
think we believe that there is at least
one true theory
um we also believe or perhaps hope that
there are not too many consistent
theories so that consistency alone might
help us guide us towards the correct
theory if there are so many theories
then consistency alone will not be able
to guide us to the correct Theory by
correct I mean the one that is described
in nature
um and also we hope that the gap between
Theory and experiment will become
smaller
now
you also mentioned the belief in Grand
unified theories there are various
things we could mean with this first I
first I indeed believe that gravity
should be put together with other forces
I think it's not mathematically
consistent to have gravity and feel
Theory completely separate there matter
creates deforms the structure of
space-time and structure of space-time
makes matter move in a different way so
they have to be fit in a consistent
mathematical structure and this is
certainly an assumption that we well
with a strong belief that we have
um now sometimes people so it's gravity
and quantity mechanics should be unified
in this way now sometimes people talk
about ground unification in the context
of cage theories this is a bit more
narrow in this case it means that there
is a very simple single big so-called
gauge group that somehow breaks into
smaller ones we have in the standard
model now I think there is a one
interesting piece of evidence for this
which is the unification of the
couplings but this is just one numerical
Queen coincidence maybe it's just a
coincidence but it's an interesting hint
now as Grand unification necessary or
always true in our more fundamental
theories such as String Theory now it's
not it depends on the particular
geometry of the internal Dimensions but
there's a more abstract sense in which
gravity and the other interaction
ceremony manifestation of the same thing
so in that that sense I think there is
some kind of identification
do you think that's right Sabina what is
what is the status of this of this
belief this belief that
um gravity and the quantum should be
reconcilable there should be one Theory
to to hold everything together
um what's the status of that conviction
is that is that a is that a Justified
belief is it an unjustified belief
but it's partly justified in the sense
that we do have an inconsistency between
general relativity and the quantum
theories of the type that the standard
model uses and this inconsistency has to
be removed resolved somehow by something
that doesn't necessarily mean that you
go and quantize gravity maybe it's
something else entirely but we need to
find some kind of resolution and yeah we
still haven't found it uh you know if we
heard you'd have heard of it
so you're not quite as um
optimistic as Michio is of about string
theories being the one that's going to
do it
uh I guess not
I mean it hasn't been going on at
Workforce to actually String Theory
right
um I mean for what it's
uh resolution of the problem of quantum
gravity is concerned strings theory has
had some other applications it was
something that Max alluded to earlier
you know often we find some piece of
mathematics and it doesn't work for one
thing but then a couple of decades later
it comes in handy for something entirely
different so um that's that certainly
very interesting but for for what
strings Theory also Theory of Everything
is concerned it hasn't been going very
well
you know the
the
adsc correspondence of course which Juan
invented
shows this beautiful Duality between on
one hand string theory and on the other
hand more traditional
particle physics even though I suspect
Juana you were motivated
by doing it very much because if you're
interested in string string theory and
using particle physics techniques to
study during Theory it's as uh Sabina
said very much been used in the opposite
direction now where people of course use
your Duality to study
heavy ion collisions and so on so
basically using string theory as a tool
for solving other problems this to me is
one of the there's also very beautiful
well I think I think this shows that
string theory is not disconnected with
the rest of physics in fact in some
sense strings have already been
discovered so strings were discovered
before String Theory wearing was
invented so what they were discovering
hadron collisions and
now usually they are not called evidence
for string theory and so on but it was
the reason why string theory was
invented and um we now think those
strings are made out of gluons out of
the particles of strong interactions
um but what the reality says is that
these two types of strength there is a
fundamental string theories and the
string theories that are made out of
gluons are not fundamentally different
they're they're similar and in some
theories we can in some theories with
supersymmetries or supersymmetry is
useful for doing calculations sometimes
and so it's like a toy model and uh for
supersymmetric theories one can show
this in in great detail one can do the
mathematical computations and show how
you know chains of blue ones turn into
Strings moving some higher Dimension and
so on
um
so I I think so String Theory had uh had
successes I think had success in
understanding how uh you could have a
perturbation Theory so how you can
calculate graviton Corrections at higher
orders
um and
how it could describe certain space
times negatively clear space times but
it's not a complete Theory yet so there
are situations we cannot describe so for
example the beginning of the universe is
something we cannot describe yet so we
don't understand how to describe it so I
would I would call String Theory not so
much as a theory but as a theory under
construction so the they're all let's
say string theory of the 80s is just an
approximation to some theory that we
think it exists but we don't know
exactly what it is and one do you think
it'll it'll get there
yeah I very much hope so
but I think people are making progress
and we're understanding more aspects now
how much more progress will I think the
most important problem to understand in
strength there is the beginning of the
Big Bang this is the most interesting
reason uh most interesting rationale for
studying quantum gravity and this is
something we don't yet know how to
describe and so max hop in and then I'd
like to hear from Michio after you Max
go for it I did that one more quick uh
reaction about the question of whether
there is a unified theory yeah I think
we humility tells us two things here one
of course we shouldn't be too confident
though with three Theory the unified
theory is going to be this Theory String
Theory or Luke quantum gravity or any
other particular Theory but I think
there's a very good argument that there
is a
theory that it's mathematical and
unifies everything in that you know we
are confused right now as physicists
about
how to put everything together right but
our universe is not confused whatsoever
it's it keeps doing its thing every day
it obviously works in in some particular
way and as long as that way is also
described by by mathematics
well that means that there is a
mathematical Theory out there for us to
discover
oh wait hang on a second though does it
mean that there's a mathematical Theory
out there for us to discuss I know I'm
like playing right into your into your
that there's a mathematical Theory out
there for us to discover or that we have
invented a particularly useful form of
mathematics
well we mustn't conflate the language of
mathematics which is the the words and
symbols we use to describe things with
with the structure that is being studied
so if a universe
is in fact some mathematical structure
you know
Einstein thought or it was uh three plus
one dimensional pseudo reminding and
manifold with some tensor Fields quantum
mechanics says it's a Hilbert space Etc
if it is something that can be described
with math and that's how it operates
right then that's very good news for us
physicists because it suggests that if
we work hard enough
maybe we can actually discover equations
which which fully captured and that is
a unified theory in the sense that you
know maybe one day someone can print a
t-shirt or something which which
from which you can actually derive
both quantum mechanics and gravity and
so on I'm just saying we shouldn't be we
should be humble
and not assume that we know which Theory
it's going to be
but there's no the inconsistences we
have are all in our heads uh that's what
I'm saying they're not in our universe
our universe doesn't show any sign of
being inconsistent
Michio you I I do I detect certainly
humility from you but you do seem to
know to think to think that you have a
good sense of which Theory it's going to
be um do you think of string theory as a
theory under construction or do you
think it's it's pretty close
I think it's pretty close
um however the progress and string
theory has been explosive because of the
work of of one and adsc ft we're talking
about taking String Theory into a new
domain that we never couldn't penetrate
before a non-perturbative domain a
domain where we think on the other side
of the fence there's ordinary Quantum
field Theory which is amazing who would
have thought that string theory would
have a double identity one identity is a
theory of gravity and the other
counterpart as a theory of ordinary
matter this is incredible so string
theory has had an explosive absolutely
explosive interest in the last few years
because of that work however there are
some flies in the ointment and I think
this hasn't been mentioned yet but I
think one of the problems of string
theory and even though I promote the
theory is the landscape problem the
theory gives you're not just something
that very closely approximates our
universe but it gives you perhaps an
Infinity of other universes a Multiverse
of universes now of course Marvel Comics
and Hollywood has discovered uh the
Multiverse uh winner of the Oscars and
so on and so forth but we physicists
take this Multiverse idea very seriously
and the way we deal with this is usually
with computers
for example when we calculate the mass
of quarks interacting with other quarks
to create subatomic particles
the human mind is not strong enough or
smart enough to do the calculation we do
it by computers with something called
lattice gauge Theory and so we've given
up trying to have the human mind master
the Dynamics of the the Quark we rely on
computers so I think and this is a long
shot that quantum computers may
eventually give us some insight into the
true vacuum of string theory and by that
I mean use the quantum to tease apart
the mysteries of the quantum digital
computers are not powerful enough to
probe the different vacuum of string
theory so I think that maybe one day a
quantum computer will be powerful enough
to probe the quantum universes that go
into a a string theory and just remember
that even ordinary quantum mechanics has
this problem quantum mechanics that's
where the whole problem of the
Multiverse originated from
so we think that something that
bedeviled ordinary quantum mechanics
well also bedel string theory and the
ultimate solution may be to use quantum
to defeat the quantum that use quantum
computers to gain insight into the true
vacua of string theory
that's fascinating
um so to take that to transition to our
our final theme and question
um we keep it seems at its limits at the
limits of uh theoretical physics in
particular
um coming up against assumptions on the
one hand and conclusions on the other
hand that may in fact remain untestable
things like the very existence of a
grand unified theory whether there might
be one out there or not the notion of
one kind of Multiverse or another kind
of Multiverse a Quantum Multiverse
string theoretical Multiverse the
inflationary Multiverse are these the
same multiverses what happens inside
black holes
um what happens what what exactly does
inflation look like there may be some
persistent untestabilities here does
this untestability to your mind
undermine the pro the the project of
physics or does it strengthen it and
Juan we will start here with you
well I I think when we talk about
physics in general I mean most of
physics is based on tested theories and
contact with experiment and so on I mean
here we're talking about the search for
the next layer so the unknown
fundamental laws of physics and I think
for this the most important thing we
could do is to continue the experimental
exploration so that the construction of
more powerful accelerators rich in
higher energy is better telescope the
telescopes that see further into the
universe including gravity wave
detectors and so on and they're also
interested in small scale experiments
searching for new particles from axions
to dark matter and so on
foreign
now so what we are talking about here is
just a very an aspect of fundamental
Theory and in particular the aspect that
has to do with quantum gravity which is
very hard to test experimentally with
our current and in future near future
experiments however it's a clear
inconsistency in our present
understanding so we could hope that by
only the consistency Criterion we could
make some progress
um it's something that had worked in the
past with uh let's say Maxwell's
equation so the development of general
relativity but that's uh that's what we
are talking about here going to very
high energy is much higher than the ones
we could reach in the near future
perhaps
perhaps if we understood the theory well
enough then we would be able to make a
prediction that we could test perhaps
through some cosmological observation
but as we said our theories are not
understood well enough to to make these
predictions
um
so I I think in general we are we are
making uh progress towards the
development of this Theory based on just
consistency
um and there are various ideas people
bring in um
I mean sometimes uh the ideas
sometimes come out of come are not
directly related to string theory so for
example there was a recent development
about holography using the so-called
yeah Guitar model so it's a model that
was inspired by condensed matter
physicists and
we were talking before about symmetries
and one interesting aspect about this
model is that it's based on disorder
random interaction so the complete lack
of symmetry so it's completely the
opposite philosophy but the the model
itself develops a kind of over there or
symmetry out of the interactions so it's
it's a new idea that people are
exploring and we're exploring we're
somehow connected with other ideas in
string theory but it's not directly
related but this is an example of how
looking how we're looking an example of
the methods we are using to looking for
the theories finding general principles
and taking ideas from other areas of
physics also
what do you think Sabina are we getting
are we getting closer here are we are
improved Technologies going to help uh
root out some of the you know the limits
that we have come across I'm going to
improve testability things like that
uh yes but probably not in the way that
uh huan envisions it
um so but first I want to say something
else so Mishu he said we physicists take
the Multiverse very seriously
I would like to object I don't take it
seriously and I'm pretty sure if you
took a representative sample of our
physicists and you asked them about it
you'd find that most of them don't take
it seriously I wanted to say this
because uh because the the sample of
physicists you see in events like this
or that you hear talking uh on the media
or something does not give you a good
impression of what most businesses
actually work on
um so um when it comes to new technology
I think where we're going to see the
most progress come from is probably
Quantum technology because there's such
a lot going on there like with Quantum
Computing Quantum Optics Quantum
information Quantum Metro biology
Quantum sensing there's so much going on
I think sooner or later they're just
stumble over something that they don't
understand and then then they'll come
and ask the theorists uh how do you
explain that uh and and then I think
from there on uh we will develop a new
Theory it it goes together with my
belief that it's a mistake to try to put
the blame on gravity when it comes to
the unification of uh Einstein's theory
and quantum theory people have tried to
doctor around with a gravity try to
quantize it I think our problem is that
we don't really understand the quantum
part of the question so this is why I
think this new technology is is going to
help us
make progress happen again the
foundations of physics
fantastic
um well it sounds like even if you uh
disagree perhaps on the status of the
Multiverse
um you're both uh hopeful that Quantum
Computing is going to help get us past
some of these some of these impasses
well thank you all so much this has been
a really wonderful conversation
um please join me in thanking our
speakers
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to The Institute of Art
and ideas at IAI TV